[Music]
hello how are you greetings andrés
gonzález with your briefing for today tuesday
july 6 this holiday weekend
was very busy for local authorities
on sunday the
north las vegas police department said seven
people were injured in a
shooting  which killed two
men prior to this three people
were killed Saturday in
separate incidents yesterday another man was
killed in a shooting north east of the
valley
on the other side a man accused of
shooting an officer with the
metropolitan police department  las vegas
with the officer's weapon appears before
a judge the incident happened on
sunday morning inside the li jing stadium
police say the ind got into a
struggle with the officers as they
tried to take him to the
security office of the establishment a second
officer  was injured in this incident
both are expected to recover and
it was also busy for the firefighters
of the  city ​​since they received
around 200 fire calls on
July 4 according to information from
the clark county fire department the
firefighters and rescuers of las vegas' on the
other hand received a total of 118
calls
and now we turn to the weather forecast
we will have extreme temperatures  for the
whole week exceeding 110 degrees
for today the three digits will remain
for the rest of the week and for
next week also have a nice
day I greet you andrés gonzález and this
may on the news now
in Spanish
[Music]